pets they're just like people except in
any meaningful way though the vast
majority of americans have a pet
according to a survey from the american
pet products association 67 of u.s
households have at least one pet this
goes all the way to the white house some
american presidents hate dogs and would
never have one in the white house and
other u.s presidents employ bloodthirsty
killing machines on white house grounds
and while we tend to think of our fur
babies as our own children what rights
do they really have even though there's
no rule that says dogs can't play
basketball could a cat inherit millions
of dollars could a dog run a fortune 500
company could a monkey own a copyright
or could an elephant run for office well
the answer is it depends because it
always depends but let's find out what
rights pets actually have because this
is america and you better believe that
this is wound up in american courts
before and it's going to end up in
courts again
and perhaps the only thing that
americans love more than lawsuits is
their pets in 2019 americans spent a
record 95.7 billion dollars on their
pets which makes sense when it comes to
our animal friends most of us would
spare no expense to ensure that they are
happy healthy and pampered like me
alexander hamilton here what happens if
you want to make sure that your own
alexander hamilton is taken care of in
the event of your untimely death well
that actually raises some interesting
legal questions let's start with the
basics well many of us may treat our
pets like people legally speaking pets
are actually considered property in the
united states as a result animals lack
the legal ability also known as capacity
to enter into a contract capacity refers
to one's demonstrated competence to
understand one's actions and enter into
a legally binding agreement with another
through mutual assent and while we may
think that our pets understand us when
after maybe one too many scotches we
tell them about the challenges of
running your own law practice and the
youtube channel under the law they do
not and since animals are property under
the law they can't enter into contracts
that means that they cannot legally
receive or own property as a result an
owner's attempt to directly leave
property to the pet will fail in the
case of in rey estate of russell a
california court of appeals addressed
whether a pet owner can legally divide
her estate between a close friend and
her dog roxy russell and the trial court
held that despite the language and the
will directly leaving property to roxy
the dog the owner actually intended to
leave her entire estate to the close
friend to care for the dog but the court
of appeals rejected this interpretation
holding instead that the will
unambiguously sought to divide the
estate between the friend and the dog
the court further rejected any argument
that the pet owner had created trust to
care for roxy as the will did not
demonstrate a specific intent to impose
on the friend the duty to care for roxy
ruling that a dog cannot be a direct
will beneficiary the court concluded
that the gifts to roxy were invalid and
accordingly half of the owner's estate
that had been intended for roxy's matter
of law went to the owner's closest
relative her niece so to avoid problems
like the russell case as of 2016 all 50
states and dc have passed laws regarding
the creation and use of so-called pet
trust a pet trust is a legal arrangement
that outlines how your pets shall be
provided for and taken care of
financially in the event of your
untimely death or disability and in the
vast majority of cases pet trusts and
gifts are non-controversial on occasion
they make international news especially
when millions of dollars are at stake
like for example in 2007 when leona
helmsley a new york billionaire real
estate developer left her maltese
trouble 12 million dollars in a trust
fund known as the queen of mean for her
cervix personality and the way that she
mistreated her employees helmsley also
specifically disinherited two of her own
grandchildren in her will
for reasons which are known to them ouch
however in 2008 a new york judge slashed
trouble's inheritance from 12 million
dollars to 2 million on the grounds that
helmsly was mentally unfit when she made
her will as a result the two
disinherited grandchildren received a
total of 6 million and despite her queen
of mean reputation helmsley clearly had
a soft spot for her dog trouble who died
in 2011 presumably on a bed of lots and
lots of money though parenthetically
that's not the only thing that she had a
soft spot for she also had a soft spot
for not paying taxes famously she said
we don't pay taxes only the little
people pay taxes and in 1989 helmsley
was convicted of federal tax income
invasion and other crimes it turns out
that not all abrasive new york real
estate developers who mistreat everyone
around them get away with not paying
their taxes though sentenced to 16 years
she only served 19 months in prison and
two months of house arrest though
helmsley was not alone in leaving
obscene amounts of money to her pet in
2019 german fashion designer carl
lagerfeld died and upon his death it was
revealed that lagerfeld had left a chunk
of his near 300 million fortune to
chopette a burmese cat though the pair
lived in france which prohibits pets
from directly inheriting their owner's
property under german law which governs
lagerfeld's will pets may inherit
property and in june 2020 it was
reported that not only were there seven
other human beneficiaries but none of
the human heirs had been able to gain
access to their share of the estate
that's because lagerfeld's octogenarian
accountant lucian fridlander the only
person with enough knowledge of
lagerfeld's vast estate to aid in the
distribution to the beneficiaries
mysteriously closed up shop in september
2019 and has been avoiding everyone's
calls fred lender's wife insisted that
her husband has not quote run off to an
island but is simply just too sick to
work on the case but of course that
definitely sounds like the sort of thing
that someone who is hiding away on a
private island might say so while
lagerfeld's beneficiaries fight for
their inheritance chopette does not even
need the money the famous feline who has
hundreds of thousands of followers on
instagram already earns millions of
euros each year by appearing in
advertising campaigns on magazine covers
and even has her own wine brand and
makeup line she's basically the cat
equivalent of the kardashians clearly
i'm in the wrong business as a lawyer
and should have pursued a lucrative
career as an international
multi-millionaire cat model so yeah i
guess i'm saying if anyone needs a
youtube bird model you know give me a
call but the past is the past speaking
of which remember in 2019 when a banana
taped to a wall sold for a hundred and
twenty thousand dollars if you found
yourself asking did a monkey make this
well not this time but there is plenty
of animal made art out there like
pockets warhol a capuchin monkey who's
been painting since 2011. and then
there's lucky the rescue elephant
painting in cambodia and while seeing
animals make art is fun it raises an
interesting question do these animals
actually own the copyright in the works
that they create i've covered copyright
law in previous videos but to summarize
briefly copyright extends legal
protection to authors of any original
work fixed in a tangible medium of
expression such as paintings songs
novels and even photographs the holder
of a copyright owns a set of exclusive
rights to make and sell copies of their
works create derivative works and
perform and display their works publicly
now the issue whether animals own the
copyright in their artistic creations
were at the forefront of what became
known as the monkey selfie case see back
in 2011 a macaque monkey named naruto i
assume that's naruto as in the anime and
not naruto as in pablo but using a
camera strategically placed by british
nature photographer david john slater
while on assignment in indonesia
famously took a monkey selfie slater
included naruto's photos in a book he
published these photos subsequently went
viral and in 2015 the people for the
ethical treatment of animals or pita
known for their attention-grabbing
protest that has made them the frequent
target for parody sued slater and the
self-publishing company blurb on
naruto's behalf the outside world looks
down on a man marrying a llama
but our love knows no boundaries
wow you guys really love animals peta
argued that publishing and selling the
photographs infringed on naruto's rights
under the u.s copyright act and peta
sought a judgment affirming naruto's
copyright in the photos and requested
the peta be appointed to administer all
proceeds from the photos for the
endangered species benefit the
defendants countered that as a monkey
naruto could not own a copyright and
while the case was pending numerous
copyright experts in both the u.s and uk
argued that slater's role in the
photographic process and his artistic
choices would be sufficient to grant him
a copyright in the photographs though a
formal court judgment might be necessary
to be determinative in fact in a
december 14 publication the united
states copyright office stated that to
qualify as a work of authorship a work
must be created by a human being
specifically stating that a photograph
taken by a monkey or a mural painted by
an animal would not receive copyright
protection and in january 2016 the u.s
district court agreed with district
court judge william orrick writing while
congress and the president can extend
the protection of law to animals as well
as humans there is no indication that
they did so in the copyright act peta
appealed to the ninth circuit court of
appeals and in september 2017 both peta
and the photographer agreed to a
settlement in which slater would donate
25 percent of any future revenue to
charities that protect the macaque
habitat unfortunately for slater the
damage was already done the litigation
had been financially devastating to him
leaving him broken unable to pay his
attorney or even replace the broken
camera equipment now after settling peta
attempted to dismiss the case but the
9th circuit refused stating that it
wanted to set a legal precedent for
similar cases that would arise in the
future the panel also ripped the animal
welfare organization for what it viewed
as peta attempting to manipulate the
legal precedent in a way that suits
their own interests and in 2018 the
ninth circuit did set a precedent
unanimously ruling that while humans can
file copyright lawsuits animals may not
and as a result the court concluded that
naruto did not own any copyright in the
photos now the three judge panel also
excoriated peta for its litigation
tactics accusing the organization of
using naruto as a tool for its own
ideological agenda while pretending to
be a friend peta appears to have failed
to live up to the title of friend in the
wake of peta's proposed dismissal naruto
is left without an advocate his supposed
friend having abandoned naruto's
substantive claims and what appears to
be an effort to prevent the publication
of a decision adverse to peta's
institutional interests were he capable
of recognizing this abandonment we
wonder whether naruto might initiate an
action for breach of confidential
relationship against his former next
friend peta for its failure to pursue
his interests before its own puzzlingly
while representing the world that
animals are not ours to eat where
experiment on used for entertainment or
abuse in any other way peta seems to
employ naruto as an unwitting pawn in
its ideological goals so there you have
it the 9th circuit says that currently
the copyright act does not apply to
animals but it could be extended to do
so and it accuses peta of treating
animals unethically but that's just
silly copyright issues what about
animals holding real power well there
have been countless movies and tv shows
over the years with the exact same story
down on their luck sports team
immediately changes their fortune by
substituting the team's animal mascot
and they all seem to get around the very
very obvious objections to such a
substitution in the exact same way well
show me in the rulebook where it says
that we can't substitute our animal
mascot of choice who happens to be
magically good at this particular sport
into our particular sports ball team
show me in the rules he's right ain't no
rule said the dog can't play basketball
lawyered just don't look at the
copyright act i guess
but in the real world although there's
no specific rule against substituting
the entire chicago bear's lineup with a
sleuth of bears yes that is the actual
group name for a group of bears in part
because the bears would always be
offsides and not for nothing they would
probably rip the opposing team to shreds
but in the late 19th century the
political term the yellow dog democrat
described southern voters who allegedly
would vote for a yellow dog before any
republican now you might be surprised to
know that many voters in u.s history
have followed that mantra
by electing animals to local office now
generally speaking election law
regulations would disqualify animal
candidates by explicitly requiring
candidates to be human or perhaps by
requiring candidates to at least perform
tasks that you know only humans can
perform such as sign their names legibly
however when the law is silent or
ambiguous on the matter
certain localities usually
unincorporated towns have allowed animal
office holders under the same logic of
airbud well there's nothing in the
election code that says we can't have a
dog mayor so let's do that apparently
for some reason and wouldn't you know it
in 1938 boston curtis a brown mule was
put forward as a candidate for a
republican precinct committeeman in the
small town of milton washington boston
was nominated by the democratic mayor
kenneth simons as a prank for two
reasons one he wanted to embarrass the
republican party and he wanted to show
the flaws of the primary system in which
voters often have no idea whom they
support the mayor would be proven
correct because humans are stupid boston
was elected with 51 of the vote despite
not offering a platform or making a
speech and being known as someone that
was stubborn as a mule and in the
unincorporated town of lajitas texas
they live up to the state's reputation
for demanding limited government since
the 1980s the town has consistently
elected members of one political dynasty
clay henry the beer drinking goat i mean
just look at him there's a kid you could
really grab a beer with now this saga
began when a man who had the audacity to
be from houston decided to run for mayor
and an outraged local businessman
challenged him with a goat though the
houstonian won that election clay henry
won the next one in a landslide and
since then every clay henry has been
elected today the town is actually under
the leadership of clay henry iv but when
it comes to electing animals to office
in the united states dogs remain by far
the most popular choice in 1981 roscoe a
black labrador rottweiler mix defeated
two humans to become mayor of cinahl
california he of course ran as a
republican on an agenda of a bone in
every dish a cat in every tree and a
fire hydrant on every corner he served
his community for 13 years until his
death and there's actually a statute in
his honor similarly idaho california is
an unincorporated town and has no local
government but since 2012 the town has
modeled its election as a fundraiser for
the benefit of a local animal rescue
non-profit organization locals would
nominate their dogs and cats to run for
mayor 14 dogs and two cats ran in the
first election and max a golden
retriever was elected as its first mayor
when mayor max crossed the rainbow
bridge in 2013 he was succeeded by
another golden retriever maximus mighty
dog mueller the second or mighty max for
short who still leads the town to this
day his oath reads i max do swear on my
food bowl to faithfully execute my
duties as mayor of idawiah the mayor's
duties include meeting with the
constituents in his pickup truck
attending city events and making a
variety of appearances on state and
local media to promote the town but of
course the downside of having a dog run
for mayor is calls like these
hello this is a paid political
advertisement from
the mayor
my name is
and i approve this message but on the
other hand mayor maximus mighty dog
miller ii probably saved a ton by making
those robo calls with today's sponsor
ting mobile and you can too in fact i
personally switched to ting mobile and
saved literally hundreds of dollars a
month i'm not kidding why well because
of this yes this is a real cell phone
bill that i got with my previous
provider and it's why i personally
switch to ting and ting mobile has three
brand new plans to make sure that never
happens again all of ting's plans have
unlimited talk and text starting at just
10 per month so you can use their flex
plan and only pay for what you use which
is especially great if you're around
wi-fi all day or you can choose a set of
12 gigabytes of data for 35
or get full unlimited for 45 dollars a
month switching plans is actually really
easy because you can keep your same
phone number and use pretty much any
phone and the service is great because
team partners with several massive
networks probably the very same one that
you're using right now but at a huge
discount they literally use the exact
same infrastructure now i can't tell you
which one specifically because i always
respect contracts and ndas but let's
just say that my service hasn't changed
at all and if you're around wi-fi all
the time like you're working from home
you still have the flexibility to save
hundreds of dollars a year with their
flex plan now they just give you the
possibility of unlimited versions as
well so if you want unlimited you can go
absolutely crazy and it's incredibly
easy to transfer service you just order
a ting sim card pop it in and set it up
no phone calls required it's like magic
but if you do ever want to talk to ting
you can call them up and talk to a human
immediately or you can talk to them on
chat or discord you will talk to real
humans virtually no wait times so if you
would like to give ting a try legal
eagles will get a 25 service credit that
could cover up to two months of service
all you have to do is click on the link
below and give it a try and you can even
use your last bill to compare just how
much you would save with their
comparison tool so just click on the
link below plus clicking on that link
really helps out this channel and while
you're there check out this playlist
with all my other legal meme reviews and
lawyer jokes so click on this playlist
or i'll see you in court